if you want to be a video Creator on
YouTube and you're not like a family
Vlog probably not going to make it on
YouTube unless you're willing to lose
lots and lots and lots of money one kind
of topic that a lot of people in our
community feel like there's mystery
around and that is um creating kids
content I think uh you know ever since
Kaa and it feeling now you check in a
box is this made for kids is it not made
for kids people wonder about
monetization um I didn't even know about
certain RPMs YouTube kids app versus the
main app
um and you've you run a couple kids
channels and so you've got experience
here in doing it in a sustainable way
first of all speak to us like fifth
grade reading level about the approach
and the strategy and the upside and the
challenges because I think also as you
tiptoe in like oh I can't do affiliate
marketing to kids I can't like can put
certain ads you know Amazon's terms of
service for example uh and that's one of
the things we talked a lot about so at
the same time it's a very legitimate
more than legitimate like there's
massive success as kids content creators
or you know content creator for children
so what are what's kind of the model
what would be the approach what are the
opportunities and what are the things
you can't do um if somebody wanted to
launch a channel directed at kids well
that's a that's a big question I mean um
starting from the top down I mean Moon
bug sold for 2.7 billion to cand media
and moon bug is a company that bought
Coco melon and blippy and uh little baby
Bomb and several other big channels uh
in the the kids space you know from a
monetization perspective like you're
generally making um you know at the high
end maybe 25 cents uh per thousand views
out of uh kids content which is a blend
of both kids app viewership and YouTube
main viewership that's both combined
yeah I mean give or take I mean that's
kind of on the lower end um you know
some of our kids properties get you know
above into the 1 two three range
depending on the average view duration
the mix of views from kids app versus
YouTube Main and then also the topic of
the video right like more educational
based content is going to outperform
like Nursery Ryme because there's such a
massive volume of viewership for nursery
rhyme that there's so much inventory and
there's just not as much of a demand for
it um in terms of like things you can
and cannot do I don't think I'm I'm
going to say anything other than like
kind of what's in the YouTube terms of
service which like if you're making kids
content you should be able to follow
anyway right they're not that Draconian
in nature but it's like basically don't
advertise to kids please you know other
than and stuff that's been vetted by our
team right because those are the only
ads that will be served on kids content
that is labeled as made for kids is
content that's been reviewed by human
and determined to be within the brand
guidelines of made for kids which and
that's not you you're just checking the
box and letting YouTube handle that
correct yeah and so does Ryan toy
reviews advertis in his content though
well I mean it depends on what you mean
by advertisement so having a yeah right
um so I was having a debate with someone
and they were talking about like the
their app it was a kid focus app like oh
yeah we don't want to have products you
know no toys and we want to have this
vertical which is science and learning
and this one that's about like your body
and health and bl we're gonna have a
gaming vertical and I was like let me
stop you right there right because a
gaming video is literally playing with a
toy for the entire video right like what
do you think a video game is it's the
game itself that you would purchase out
the app store or in app purchases you
get downloads yeah ex exactly and so
like you know they kind of like HED and
like well you know it's gaming content
so whatever right and it's it's kind of
like this weird subjective line right of
what is or is not safe for kids at a
macro level and then what is or is not
safe for your kids right I think
generally speaking YouTube within the
kids app does a pretty good job they're
not perfect no one is world's biggest
plat platform you know trillions of
views you know lots and lots of you know
people uploading and by far the vast
majority just want to make cool stuff
that people enjoy but you know anytime
you know there's a there's a party
that's massive someone wants to come
along and ruin it right um and people
have ruined the YouTube kids experience
multiple times in the past and so like
you know it is it is restrictive your
content's not going to show up in the
kids app for sometimes weeks um until
it's been reviewed by a human but uh in
an effort to keep safe and protect the
industry and make sure advertisers
aren't afraid to advertise within
YouTube kids and parents aren't afraid
to put the YouTube kids app in front of
their kids um you know it's it's what's
got to be done so like there are some
restrictions but generally speaking it's
going to be fine I want to invite you
guys to our YouTube 1K challenge you can
join this challenge for free as we show
you how to grow your first 1,000
subscribers and make your first $11,000
on YouTube we've had countless people
join us during this 1K challenge who are
now at 1,000 subscribers and past 1,000
subscribers making money on YouTube and
you could be the next person if you just
go to 21k challenge.com you can sign up
for the very next challenge and we can't
wait to see you guys there what kind of
numbers if if you know the math off the
top of your head when I think about
blippy these days and now as a dad of a
2 and a halfy old and 9month old this is
why I'm now the most educated
connoisseur of kids cont I never even
watched it before and now I'm like a
blippy expert and Ma and the fake B
blippy second actor he's at scale but
it's actually a pretty cool story
because he started super simple and and
had to build up everybody started at
zero I think that for some kids channels
I think it's kind of an uphill battle
but it would seem at RPMs of those
numbers and the inability to advertise
that you you could just do the math
you'd say okay if I wanted to do this
like full let's say I want to work back
from Mak it a sixf fig business because
I want to have a couple Freelancers
helping me I want to film and then I
could pay my bills and I could maybe do
that at like 100k then if I'm doing the
views play then I need to calculate the
math that I need millions of views oh uh
for sure well if you're getting a $1 RPM
right you need 100 million monthly views
100 million monthly right because
that'll give you wait that's 100K a
month well that would be 100K a month so
if you got 100 million views in a year
at a $1 RPM then you'd make $100,000 in
a year right and but if you're at 25
cent RPM you need 400 million yeah you
need half a trillion and that that would
be on long form yeah exactly is short
form even for kids yeah they're a lot of
short form in the kids app they're
they're very uh bullish on that and
pushing that um but that would also be
would it be similar to the YouTube
shorts I've seen get about two four six
maybe N9 Cent RPMs on for adults yeah
that I mean you're not mon you're you
can write off the monetization for
shorts and kids basically there is some
but it's like a fraction of a fraction
exactly it's it's impossible without
being like family vloggers to create a
sustainable kids content business on
YouTube in in my view pretty much
anywhere else right unless you're
pitching Studios who are going to
finance it da da like if you want to be
a video Creator on YouTube and you're
not like a family Vlog probably not
going to make it on YouTube unless
you're willing to lose lots and lots and
lots of money up front as you're scaling
up to 400 and and and for a at scale
organization six fig is not even a ton
of money if you have it's you know but
if so so the solo Creator though could
work back from that math what kind of
content could I create that would get
400 million views a year that's it's
like lottery ticket sure style right
like it's just it's not an environment
where that's going to happen now the
immediate kind I thought after that like
well what if you can layer in licensing
and syndication and merchandise and
that's where thing it's like well what
individual has that skill set or the
time sure to do that right if you're
trying to put together like a 20 minute
you know video a week you're a single
entrepreneur it's just not realistic
unless you're like family vloggers got
it right um you're not going to animate
that much that fast right like you're
just not going to you know cast people
or hire like it's just not realistic in
the kids space I will it's as
interesting and I don't know their uh
name off the top but they came up to me
they actually were a part of our
community they've been watching for
years they are creating VR content
they've created a character they film it
in the VR world and edit it in like
Premiere um and they said they're more
like teen audience uh and kind of maybe
like Chad W clay which I think Their
audience is aged up a little bit maybe
or is that kids
content that's not family blogging I
mean it's it was definitely not family
vlogging I think they make interesting
stories um you know it's it's an example
I often give when I talk about like one
of the first successful narrative you
know web series um and they blend it
with all these other formats it's
brilliant I love Chad and I love v um
but I think there are audiences from Age
4 to 18 that can enjoy what they're
doing yeah um and so like I don't think
they make it specifically for kids right
they don't necessarily often feature or
or ever from what I've seen like toys or
products that are aimed at kids they
don't necessarily like speak to kids or
uh and there's no kids in their content
right they're what probably in their 30s
at this point um so so like no I think
it's I think they make content for a
wide age group um that uh you know isn't
necessarily made for kids so that could
be the approach there if they're not
checking the box but can that content
find its way to the kids app yeah um in
in two kind of ways actually um one
would be like YouTube reviews the
content and decides that it's made for
kids yeah um which I have all sorts of
not sa for work thoughts and opinions on
that dichotomy but um the second way is
um YouTube Just sees that the content is
popular with that age group and puts it
in there um one example I heard them
give was like well baseball highlights
right there's lots of kids on the kids
app they love watching baseball right
and so you know the baseball highlights
most of them are safe for work right and
so they put them in the kids app and
kids enjoy watching them okay so just in
recap for kids creators and aspiring
kids creators that's going to be a tough
model to get a su in the creater economy
if you need to even get enough views if
you're checking the box and content is
just for kids however if you're a family
vlogger um then that is the exception
and then there's also this kind of line
of maybe your there's lots of content
formats that might be interesting to
kids but you're not checking the box
they're not directed to kids it might be
very popular there and so very
interesting if you enjoyed this content
and want to take your YouTube channel to
the next level just click or tap the
link on the screen or go to tube 1K
challenge.com to join our next live
YouTube challenge you'll learn our best
tips and strategies that are working
here at think media and I think you'll
love it